- LA definitely steps
it up with the fashion.
- LA cool, but Tampa is where it's at.
We bosses around here.
(upbeat music)
- To me, LA is the best
city on the planet.
- Tampa is everything.
It's amazing.
- I don't want to be mean
about Tampa, but come on.
- Tampa is the best city in the world.
I love my city.
- LA real estate is more
expensive, but more amazing.
- There's more family
oriented things here in Tampa.
- LA is better than Tampa because-
- Where else can you rub
elbows with Hollywood's elite?
- You should move to Tampa
versus LA because of the traffic.
When you go to the beach,
the water is actually warm.
- LA, it's like the perfect
mix between New York and Miami.
There's the nightlife,
also nice restaurants and nice people.
- LA is the very best city out
there because of the weather,
the ocean, the mountains,
the glam, entertainment,
and of course, the real estate.
- We have the laid back beach lifestyle.
We have professional
sports teams that win.
- And by the way,
I think the Superbowl's
coming over here too,
so good luck, Tampa.
- Tampa is a very welcoming
city, very family friendly.
- I lived in Florida and the
weather there is extremely hot.
- LA people are cocky, beautiful.
- I think that Tampa
people are more laid back.
- In Los Angeles,
we have unbelievably exciting
architecture and real estate.
I mean, I don't think there's a
better city in the world
for real estate.
- LA is the center of everything.
- Can I say that LA is pretentious?
- I can't diss LA.
LA does have the style,
but we've got it too.
We don't have to do too much
because we in warm weather,
so we can throw on a two
piece and call it a day.
- Our real estate in LA is way better.
- You should come to
Tampa, as opposed to LA,
because you can enjoy summer year round.
- I'm sure there are
people that live there,
but I don't think I've ever been.
- People from LA wanna be in Tampa,
because they're buying
the houses. (laughs)